Là, on est en plein vote du Parlement européen.
Les Allemands sont votés ou rejetés
les uns après les autres.
Et. Euh, c'est à propos de.
On va reprendre en voix-off,
ça sera plus simple.
Et le défi du jour,
c'est de t'expliquer en moins de 2minutes
à quoi sert le Parlement européen.
C'est dans cet émicycle, au siège de Strasbourg,
que débattent sept-cent-cinq euros députés,
dont 79 français.
Lui, pour 5 ans, ensemble,
il représente près de
quatre-cent-cinquante-millions d'europeins.
Les euros députés se réunissent ici 12 fois par an,
généralement 1 fois par mois, pendant 3 jours et demi,
durant ce qu'on appelle les sessions pleinières.
Le reste du temps, il travaille surtout à Bruxelles.
Le parlement,
c'est la seule institution de l'Union européenne
directement élu par les citoyens, et ce depuis 45 ans.
Chaque pays est représenté par 1 nombre de députés
différents en fonction de son nombre d'habitants.
Et les députés ne se regroupent pas par pays,
mais par groupe politique
partageant des idées en commun.
Promis, on vous les présentera dans 1 prochaine vidéo.
D'abord,
faut que je vous explique ce que je voulais dire par,
en fait, les zéros députés ont 3 grands pouvoirs,
le pouvoir de contrôle,
le pouvoir budgetaire et le pouvoir législatif
qu'il partage avec le conseil de l'Union européenne.
Le conseil, c'est 1 autre
institution de l'Union européenne qui
représente les gouvernements des États membres.
Ensemble, ces 2
institutions votent et donc
adoptent les lois de l'Union européenne.
Ces lois, on les appelle Directives,
et elles sont
importantes car elles priment en théorie
sur le droit national de chaque pays.
Par contre, attention,
le parlement ne peut pas lui-même
proposer les lois européennes.
C'est la Commission européenne,
1 sorte de
gouvernement européen qui a toujours l'initiative.
C'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on reproche souvent au
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne,
le parlement doit ensuite débattre de ses lois,
et les amandés amandés,
ça veut pas dire mettre des amendes,
mais ça veut dire modifier le texte de la loi.
Par exemple,
sugérer 1 objectif plus ambitieux que ce qu'avait
proposé la commission,
c'est moins 30%, non, c'est moins 40%.
Ce travail de modification,
ils le font en plus petit groupe, qu'on appelle
commission parlementaire
et qui sont spécialisés sur le sujet concerné.
Ils discutent pendant plusieurs mois à Bruxelles,
et quand le texte est prêt,
ils le soumettent au vote de la pleinière,
c'est-à-dire les sept-cent-cinq députés dans les
musiques de Strasbourg.
Et là, il y a encore la possibilité de
modifier le texte en proposant de nouveaux
abandonnements.
Oui, je sais, c'est 1 peu compliqué.
Nous, au moment où on est arrivé dans les missiles,
ils étaient justement en train de voter
ou rejeter des dizaines
et des dizaines d'abandonnements,
à main levée ou avec leur boîtier de votes
sur 1 nouvelle loi pour la
promotion de la réparation des biens de consommation.
Voilà, maintenant
t'en sais 1 peu plus sur pourquoi les
prochaines élections
européennes sont importantes.
Mais n'hésite pas à t'abonner si tu veux.
tout ce que tu dois savoir avant les élections
le neuf/06.